have you ever struggled identified
letters from a distorted image or find
all it takes you to the fire hydrant or
traffic light or maybe you've been
baffled by how simple it is to click on
the checkbox to verify you are a human
oftentimes these tests either seem too
easy for BOTS to do or too hard for
humans to do so how do they actually
work at stopping Vox well starting off
CAPTCHA which stands for completely
automated public Turing test to tell
computers and humans apart is used to
prevent BOTS from spamming on websites
by creating multiple accounts or posting
several messages now why exactly someone
would spam using BOTS I don't know but
that's beside the point how are these
tests able to successfully stop these
spots well originally CAPTCHA tests were
simple distorted text which were images
if you have ever scanned the document
and tried to ctrl F something in the
document you may have realized that most
programs cannot find text within an
image and this is what CAPTCHA took
advantage of people can read text on
images but the computers these were
simply a conglomeration of random pixels
but as time passed along an optical
character recognition programs evolved
these tests became easier and easier for
BOTS to crack and this is why the
texting CAPTCHA became more and more
distorted if you ever struggled a
correctly identifying these distorted
letters well you're not alone at a point
these letters became so distorted in an
effort to fight against advancing BOTS
that they actually became too hard for
humans to discern in fact in 2014 before
the switch - I am NOT a robot checkbox
computers got CAPTCHA test right
ninety-nine point eight percent of the
time while humans only got it right 33
percent of the time so clearly this was
not keeping out the right demographic as
a result after a few years of
development Google came out with
reCAPTCHA as a replacement this is what
you usually come across today the iconic
I am NOT a robot checkbox sometimes
followed up by identifying crosswalks
and traffic lights so how did these
checkboxes work they seem to be much
easier than discerning to store the text
well
Google doesn't officially release a
recapture works
for obvious reasons but the community
has over the past couple of years
developed some key points that Google
uses to determine if you're a human that
are surprisingly effective starting off
when every CAPTCHA is presented to you
the website tracks your mouse movements
see us humans are stupid and are not
very nimble with the mouse we are unable
to move it in a linear fashion at a
constant speed
we often jitter or move it in an arc
fashion with random spurts of speed we
may overshoot the check box and move our
mouse back to click it on the edge
before all of this we may have taken a
second or two to even realize where the
check box is see the problem for robots
is that they are too intelligent to make
such stupid human errors they are able
to identify the check box within
milliseconds swiftly moved them in
linear fashion and then click on center
of them computers are extremely
efficient but one place where there's
chocolate lot is in trying to replicate
human behavior and this carries on to a
following test as well if you are asked
to identify a crosswalk or traffic light
you may move a mouse over each slide and
think about it for a couple of seconds
before choosing one of the slides a
computer on the other hand would simply
analyze an image in a split second and
choose the correct slides as a result
Google isn't checking if you click all
the slides with crosswalks correctly but
rather monitoring how you interact with
the image they may actually throw in
traffic lights that are notoriously hard
for humans to spot so if you exhibit a
human mouse behavior and miss one of the
slides with traffic lights you may
actually still be a lot forward so
essentially Google realized that robots
are much smarter than humans so testing
for intelligence simply would not work
as a result the newer reCAPTCHA
basically tests if you exhibit behavior
that is less than perfect ironically to
get to reCAPTCHA
you have to act dumber than a computer
would but it's not just how you interact
with the images either Google also takes
advantage of a recent activity on Google
perhaps you misspelled a word as you
were searching Google or maybe you click
on several different links before
landing on the page you are currently on
furthermore we will takes into account
how often you create new accounts or try
to post security researchers say that
cool takes advantage of cookies browser
Bute and traffic patterns it also takes
into account if you're using a VPN or
have anti tracking extensions
these can actually all lead to you
feeling a reCAPTCHA but all these
methods of testing are just temporary
machine learning is constantly getting
better and their ability to mimic human
behavior will eventually be on point so
not only will both be able to analyze
video audio and images better than us
but also act as human as us and in fact
an engineering lead at Google claims as
such blockades will only prove effective
for another five to ten years after this
we will most likely have to turn to
constant tests running in the background
as we surf the web so as a recap BOTS
had trouble completing CAPTCHA in the
past as they were not capable of
analyzing and successfully completing
Turing tests but as BOTS have gotten
smarter these tests have started to rely
on human behavior to determine if a user
is human currently it is difficult for
bots to emulate human behavior but that
too will one day change and then we will
have to deal with constant monitoring
but that's why bots can't complete
reCAPTCHA right now if you guys thought
this video explained this process well
then make sure drop a like and subscribe
if I see more questions just like this
one answered logically but until then
I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on the
next one